es ist wahrscheinlich der spannendste
job im universum so sieht es die nasa
zitat der beste job auf der erde und im
universum die us-raumfahrtbehörde sucht
nach neuen astronauten astronauten und
es warten extremen spannende aufgaben
doch die kriterien sind super streng und
nicht jeder kann sich bewerben
doch wer ausgewählt wird hat ein ganz
besonderes ziel pixum science fiction
hier gibt's die spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's sie will kommen schon vor drei
jahren 2017 hatte die nasa nach neuen
leuten für das weltraum team gesucht und
die auswahl war nicht ohne
denn es gingen mehr als 18.000
bewerbungen insgesamt elf frauen und
männer wurden damals ausgesucht
mittlerweile haben die alle ihre
ausbildung beendet und gehören mit zum
weltraum team der nasa das aus knapp 50
aktiven astronautinnen astronauten
besteht der ganze prozess geht jetzt
wieder von vorne los zwischen dem
zweiten und 31 märz diesen jahres 2020
kann man sich wieder bei der nasa
bewerben doch es gibt nicht wenige
voraussetzungen zum einen muss man einen
master abschluss in einem
naturwissenschaftlichen studienfach
vorweisen und mindestens zwei jahre
berufserfahrung mitbringen alternativ
werden auch mindestens 1000 stunden
flugtraining anerkannt weiterhin dürfen
sich nur leute bei der nasa bewerben die
die us staatsbürgerschaft haben dazu
twitter die nasa hitlers manns
graduation made you daydream about your
own out of this adventure-fans du bns
application for the next artemis asset
class will be accepted vom much to the
waves bevor man sich dann für die
astronautik klasse qualifiziert steht
noch ein fitness-test und außerdem auch
ein online assessment dass etwa zwei
stunden in anspruch nehmen soll
die besten bewerbungen gehen dann an
eine jury aus aktuellen astronautin
astronauten und genau die wählen dann
die vielversprechendsten leute aus vor
allem zählt hier wohl praktische
erfahrung vor allem in sachen leben und
tod vorweisen können dass beispielsweise
leute die zuvor schon im militär
gearbeitet haben oder aber leute wie die
astronautin catherine die zuvor an ebola
virus
forscht hatte das training der
ausgewählten bewerberinnen und bewerber
ist nicht ohne und sehr intensives
besteht aus weltraumspaziergang
simulation unter wasser virtual reality
experimenten und russisch unterricht
zudem wird unterrichtet wie man ein ei
ss protokoll anfertigt und sich einen
roboterarm steuern lässt auch der flug
mit kampfjets wird gelernt dazu die nasa
sprecherin
brandy den entscheidungen dort können
über leben und tod entscheiden
du musst bereit sein mit allem umzugehen
was da passieren könnte
zwei jahre training also wird es dann
geben bevor die angehenden
astronautinnen astronauten aufträge
bekommen dann könnten sie möglicherweise
mit einem raumschiff liegen vielleicht
sogar zum mond denn bis 2024 will die
us-raumfahrtbehörde ja wie der menschen
dorthin schicken
das dient als vorbereitung und bis mitte
der 2030er jahre die ersten menschen zum
mars zu fliegen dazu der chef der nasa
jim briten stein es ist eine
unglaubliche zeit in der menschlichen
raumfahrt um an astronaut zu sein und
tatsächlich ist der job an wirklich
super spannender und besondere das zeigt
das beispiel der us astronautin
christina koch die erst anfang februar
diesen jahres 2020 nach 3 128 tagen auf
der internationalen raumstation iss
wieder auf der erde gelandet war ein
neuer rekord denn damit ist sie die frau
die die längste zeit am stück im all
verbracht hat aber nicht nur dass
christina koch hat in dieser zeit an
spannenden experimenten teilgenommen
konkret ging es um die auswirkungen von
langzeit raumflügen dazu sagt die
astronauten in einem interview mit cnn
das ist eine wunderbare sache für die
wissenschaft wir sehen einen neuen
aspekt davon wie der menschliche körper
über lange zeit von der schwerelosigkeit
beeinflusst wird und das ist sehr
wichtig für unsere geplanten zukünftigen
raumfahrtaktivitäten zum mond und zum
mars
christina koch hatte außerdem zusammen
mit der astronautin jessica meyer den
ersten rein weiblichen außenbordeinsatz
durchgeführt insgesamt hat die nasa seit
den 60er jahren schon 350 astronauten
astronauten ausgebildet dazu die nasa
sprecherin brandy die das ist der beste
job auf der erde und im universum alles
über neil armstrong der erste mann auf
dem mond anklicken anschauen und
weltraum wissen von astro comics
abonnieren
einer meiner lieblings kanäle bis dann
bleibt dran